Wired's beam is the most exciting story
of our time it's the transformation of
our planet on the most fundamentalist
wired emission to report on the most
important story of our time which was a
digital revolution and its mission was
to make this revolution understandable
we weren't prisoners of objectivity our
mission was to deliver reality Moore's
law has been predicting the doubling of
processor speed every 18 months well we
talked about the death of advertising we
talked about the death of politics the
idea that that change was so
overpowering that old things were just
going to go away and all of those
notions were way optimistic or just way
wrong the state is still around politics
is still around advertising is still
around on the other hand we certainly
called the economic progress that we're
seeing around the world and we did get
right the fact that that the internet
would provide an alternative connection
to reality that had previously been the
monopoly of media I remember the story
that we did with Bruce Sterling on the
future of war which is the first cover
story the person that we were using to
represent it wasn't a soldier or
represent the story was the actual
person who wrote the story wired
consistently put its authors on the
cover the office became the heroes of
the book whether it was Bruce and that
issue we had dug copeland on it on a
cover we had Neal Stephenson on a cover
and we did this consistently throughout
at least my time on the magazine other
stories we wrote the second issue we had
a story on on cypherpunks john gilmore
that was a cover story where they were
they were masked on the cover of one
story that I am particularly happy that
we did was about a mid twentieth century
philosopher by the name of tired the
Chardin but what he was saying was that
electronic technology was part of God's
plan for evolution the planet was being
enrolled in
in an electronic brain that he called
the Noah sphere the world is radically
different than it was 15 years ago and I
categorised that as a revolution in fact
we were saying that the Russian
Revolution was like a schoolyard game
compared to the change it's been driven
by the digital revolution we're arriving
at new ways of appreciating the world
around us understanding the world around
us acting in them in the world around us
and simultaneously creating another
level of consciousness as we all connect
of each other these days if you're at a
party and you want to show you're well
informed just quote from the most recent
issue of wired san Francisco's
revolutionary magazine about digital
culture and then there's the electronic
version hot-wired way New Journalism but
then you already knew that didn't you
you